hello and welcome to this week in
Android development for july 22nd 2013
live from our brand new android
broadcast studio my name is reto Meier
last week the Google Play Games team put
on a show to help your web games take
advantage of Google Play game services
and the Android design in action team
cast a critical eye over one of our GDG
app clinic Oslo apps as well as
providing some insight into how to
create a consistent design for your apps
our Australian colleagues held their
first fireside chat on making apps
beautiful on Android developers
backstage and anchor followed up with
the next of his dev bytes explaining how
to make your apps beautiful on tablets
not to be outdone chet was back for an
exciting episode of his animation dev
bytes more on that later the android
developer survey is still open but it
closes this week this is your chance to
tell us what works and what doesn't or
just that we ask far too many questions
next week anchors back for more
beautiful active bites and chat well you
just have to wait and see what Chet's
got in store last Friday's cricketing
humiliation delayed our scheduled
episode of the app clinic when a
drinking game involving the fall of
Australian wickets went horribly wrong
it's been rescheduled for this week but
Australian viewers beware it contains
screenshots taken during the second test
this episode is a little different from
a usual app clinic format with a deep
dive into the architectural decisions
and design that go into creating an
efficient low latency sports score
tracking app so tune in and find out how
to make your apps architecture as
beautiful as its visual design as always
you can go to developers.google.com /
life / android to see what we've got
planned for a deal this coming week
that's all for this week in Android
development for july 22nd 2013 and
remember that the dust from a distance
sun will shower over everyone